Cette conférence est vraiment centrée sur la révolution digitale,
mais je dois vous avouer que c'est fait. On a gagné !
La révolution digitale a déjà eu lieu, on a pas besoin d'une révolution permanente.
Et j'ai envie de voir plus loin,
de voir ce qui nous attend après la revolution digitale.
Projetons nous donc dans l'avenir.
Voilà quelques projets dans lesquels je suis impliqué, au MIT,
où nous regardons ce qui vient après les ordinateurs.
Le premier, c'est "l'internet Zero", en haut à gauche. C'est un serveur web
qui n'est pas plus complexe qu'une puce électronique et coute le même prix,
à peu près un dollar-- elle peut être utilisée dans n'importe quelle ampoule ou interrupteur.
et va etre commercialisée sous peu.
Ce qui est intéressant, ce n'est pas tellement son coût,
mais la façon dont internet est codé par cette puce.
Elle utilise une sorte de signal en morse pour Internet
qui peut être transmis par des ondes optiques, mais aussi acoustique,
par les prises de courant, ou des ondes radios
On a pris le principe même d'internet,
qui est de créer des réseaux decentralisés d'ordinateurs
et faire en sorte que les appareils eux-mêmes soient interconnectés.
On peut prendre l'idée de base qui a donnée naissance à Internet
et la transcrire au monde matériel dans ce concept d'Internet Zero.
ce réseau qui connecte les appareils eux-mêmes.
C'est la prochaine étape pour passer de là à là,
et c'est en train d'être commercialisé en ce moment.
L'étape d'après, c'est l'ordinateur en pâte.
Les biens indiscernables peuvent etre echangés et achetés.
Ainsi, moitié moins de grains, est moitié moins utile
mais un demi-bébé ou un demi- ordinateur, c'est bien moins utile
qu'un bébé ou qu'un ordinateur entier,
et on a toujours essayé de ne faire que des ordinateurs comme ca.
Ce que vous voyez en arrière plan, c est un prototype.
C'était la thèse d'un étudiant, Bill Butow, maintenant à Intel,
qui s'est posé la question, si plutôt que de faire des puces de plus en plus grosses,
on ne pouvait pas faire des puces plus petites, mais les mettre dans un milieu visqueux,
et déverser la puissance de calcul au kilogramme.
Et c'est ce que vous voyez là.
A gauche, c'est une image rendue par un ordinateur conventionel,
et sur la droite, l'image est rendue par le prototype
que nous avons fabriqué, sans mémoire tampon, processeur
ni autre chose comme ca- c'est juste le matériel en lui même.
A la différence de cet écran, où les pixels sont placés minutieusement,
c'est de la matiére première.
Si vous en avez deux fois plus, vous pouvez afficher deux fois plus de choses
Si vous tirez une balle de pistolet au travers, rien ne se passe.
Si vous désirez plus de ressources, vous n'avez qu'à étaler plus d'ordinateur.
C'est l'étape d'après: l'informatique sous forme de matière étalable.
Mais c'est encore des bits conventionels, et l'étape d'après est--
et c'est un prototype naissant dans un labo
c'est une vidéo ultra-rapide ralentie.
Maintenant, on intègre la chimie dans le calcul, et les bits deviennent des bulles.
Cette vidéo montre comment sont générés les bits, et là,
une nouvelle fois, au ralentit pour que vous puissiez voir,
les bits interagissent de façon logique en se combinant.
Donc maintenant, on peut faire des calculs dont le résultat est un arrangement de la matière,
tout autant que de l'information. Et, pour finir, voici des planches
d'un de mes anciens projets, de calcul avec stockage de l'information
de façon quantique dans le noyau des atomes. Ainsi,
les programmes rearrangent la structure des noyaux des atomes et molécules.
Tout ça existe dans les laboratoires, allant de plus en plus loin,
et ce n'est pas une métaphore, mais on intègre littéralement les bits et les atomes,
et ça nous ammène au constat suivant.
Nous savons tous qu' on a eu une révolution digitale, mais qu'est ce c'est?
En fait, Shannon nous a ammené dans les années 40, d'ici a ici:
du téléphone qui était un simple haut parleur dont la qualité se dégrade avec la distance
à Internet. Et il a prouvé le premier théorème sur les seuils, qui montre
que si une information est additionnée puis retranchée à une porteuse,
on peut calculer de façon exacte avec des instruments inexacts.
Et c'est ça qui a donné Internet.
Von Neumann, dans les années 50, a fait la même chose pour le calcul numérique.
il a montré qu'on peut avoir un ordinateur imparfait, mais qu'en restaurant sa configuration,
il peut être rendu parfait. Ce fut le dernier ordinateur analogique à MIT:
un analyseur différentiel, qui, plus il était utilisé,
plus il donnait une réponse fausse.
Après Von Neumann, nous avons eu les Pentium, ou le milliardieme transisteur,
est aussi fiable que le premier.
Mais toute la fabrication est dans ce coin en bas à gauche.
Une tour à métaux de nouvel génération pour l'industrie aéronautique,
voir peut-être une machine pour faire fondre du plastique. Une machine a 10 million de dollars
qui utilise un procédé que n'inporte quel artisan de village reconnaitrait:
vous étendez de la matière et la faites cuire.
Et toute l'ingéniosité du système est externe au système lui-même.
la matière ne contient pas d'information.
Hier, on entendait parler de biologie moléculaire,
qui calcule pour construire.
C'est un système qui traite de l'information.
Nous avons eu des révolutions digitales en communication et calcul numérique,
mais la même idée, précisément la même logique,
qu'ont développée Shannon et Von Neuman, n'a pas encore éclos
dans le monde physique, dans la fabrication. Ainsi, inspirés par cela,
des collègues dans ce programmes, le Center for Bits and Atoms
au MIT-- qui forment un groupe de personnes, comme moi
qui n'ont jamais compris la limite entre la science du tangible
et les sciences informatiques. Je dirais même plus,
les sciences informatiques sont la pire chose qui soit arrivée
à la fois aux ordinateurs et à la science---
(rire)
-- parce que les canons -- les sciences informatiques --
nombres d'entre eux sont géniaux, mais les canons des sciences informatiques
a gelé l'évolution des modèles de calcul
selon la technologie qui était disponible dans les années 50,
mais la nature est un ordinateur bien plus puissant que ça.
Vous allez entendre demain Saul Griffith. C'est l'un des premiers élèves
a être sorti de ce programme.
Nous avions commencé a comprendre comment calculer pour fabriquer.
Il a juste fait une preuve de principe, de tuiles
qui interagissent comme des magnets. En écrivant un code,
un peu comme le replis des protéines, on va imposer une certaine structure a ces tuiles.
Ainsi, il n'y a pas de boucle de retour par un appareil de mesure,
le matériau lui-même code pour sa propre structure, exactement comme
sont fabriquées les protéines. Ainsi, vous pouvez faire ca par exemple.
Vous pouvez faire bien d'autres choses. C'est du 2D, mais ça marche aussi en 3D.
La vidéo dans le coin en haut à droite -- je ne vais pas la montrer par manque de temps --
montre l'auto-réplication, l'arrangement. ainsi, quelque chose peut faire quelque chose d'autre
qui peut faire encore autre chose. Et nous arrivons à faire ça, sur, peut-être,
neuf ordres de grandeurs. Ces idées ont été utilisées pour montrer
la ressemblance et le taux de réplication de l'ADN pour faire un organisme.
en fonctionalisant des nanoclusters avec des queues de peptides
qui codent pour leur assemblage. Ainsi, tout comme des magnets,
mais à des échelles nanométriques.
L'usinage laser: des imprimantes 3D qui fabriquent de façon digitale,
des systèmes fonctionnels, jusqu'à la construction de bâtiments,
non pas avec des plans d'architectes,
mais en aillant des briques qui déterminent la forme du bâtiment.
Ce sont des exemples de technologies emergeant dans les laboratoires
pour la fabrication digitale. Des ordinateurs qui ne controllent pas des outils
mais des ordinateurs qui sont des outils, pour lesquels le résultat d'un programme
est un réarrangement d'atomes tout autant que des bits.
Maintenant, pour faire ca -- avec l'argent de vos impots, merci --
j'ai acheté toutes ces machines. Nous avons fait une demande modeste
à notre organisme de financement. Nous voulions pouvoir créer tout, de n'importe quelle taille,
le tout dans un seul espace, parce qu'on ne peut pas faire de ségregation pour la fabrication digitale
par discipline ou par la taille.
Ainsi, nous avons regroupé des imprimantes spécialisées,
des machines pour découper avec de l'eau sous pression, des systèmes pour l'usinage de précision.
Mais nous avions un problème. Une fois qu'on a reçu toutes ces machines,
je passais un part trop importante de mon temps à former les élèves pour l'utilisation de ces machines.
Ainsi, j'ai commencé à enseigner une classe, appelée modestement,
"Comment fabriquer presque tout". Et je ne voulais pas être provocateur,
c'était juste pour quelques élèves chercheurs.
Mais le premier jour, la classe ressemblait à ça.
Vous savez, des centaines de personnes, qui viennent en priant
toute ma vie, j'ai voulu prendre un cours comme ca. Je ferais n'importe quoi pour le faire.
Ensuite, ils demandent: Ca peut etre enseigné au MIT? Ca à l'air trop utile?
Et ensuite...
(rire)
la chose la plus surprenante, c'est qu'ils n' étaient pas là pour faire de la recherche.
Ils étaient là parce qu'ils voulaient fabriquer des choses.
Ils n'avaient pas le bagages technique conventionel.
Et après un semestre, ils avaient des compétences nouvelles.
Je vais vous montrer une ancienne vidéo. Kelly était sculpteur, et voilà ce qu'elle a fait
pour son projet de classe.
(Video): Kelly: Bonjour, je m'appelle Kelly et c'est mon compagnon de cri.
Vous êtes vous déjà trouvé dans une situation
où vous voulez crier, mais vous ne pouvez pas parce que vous êtes au boulot,
dans une salle de cours, en train de surveiller vos enfants,
ou dans un tas d'autres situations où ce n'est juste pas permis?
Et bien, le compagnon de cri est un espace portable pour crier.
Quand l'utilisateur crie dans son compagnon de cri, son cri est silencieux.
C'est aussi enregistré pour une libération ultérieure, où, quand et comment
l'utilisateur le désire.
(cri)
(rires) (applaudissements)
Einstein aurait adoré.
Cet élève a fait un navigateur internet pour perroquets --
laissons les perroquets surfer sur le net, et parler avec d'autres perroquets.
Cet élève a fait un réveil contre lequel il faut se battre
pour prouver que vous êtes bien réveillé, celui là défend--
c'est un costume qui défend votre espace personnel.
Ce n'est pas de la technologie pour la communication;
c'est une technologie pour se protéger d'elle.
C'est un instrument qui vous permet de voir votre musique.
Là, c'est un élève qui fait une machine qui fait d'autres machines,
et il fait cela grâce a des briques Légo qui transmettent l'information.
Année après années-- et j'ai finalement pris conscience
que les élèves prouvaient que les applications ultimes de la fabrication maison
sont des produits pour un marché de une personne.
Vous n'avez pas besoin de ça pour faire ce que vous pourriez acheter au Walmart;
vous avez besoin de ça pour faire des choses uniques.
Ken Olson a dit un jour, personne n'a besoin d'un ordinateur à la maison.
Mais vous ne l'utilisez pas pour faire des inventaires ou vos comptes.
#####. Vous n'avez pas besoin de la fabrication personnelle
à la maison pour faire ce que vous pourriez acheter, parce que vous pourriez l'acheter.
Vous en avez besoin pour faire ce qui vous rend unique, tout comme la personnalisation.
Ainsi, aujourd hui, on peut faire ça avec 20 millions de dollars,
dans 20 ans, on fera des replicateurs façon Star Trek qui feront n'importe quoi.
Les élèves prenaient les machines que j'avais achetée en otages, pour faire de la fabrication personnelle.
Aujourd'hui, quand vous depensez autant d'argent,
le gouvernement demande que vous fassiez du travail de proximité, ce qui veut souvent dire
des cours dans des écoles voisines, un site-internet; tout un tas d'activités pas très passionnantes.
Donc je me suis mis d'accord avec le directeur du programme qui me finance que,
plutôt que de parler du système, je donne aux gens l'accès aux machines.
Ce n'était pas fait pour être important ou provocateur,
mais nous avons assemblé ces laboratoires de fabrication. Environ 20,000 dollars d'équipement
qui peuvent presque faire la même chose que notre laboratoire a 20 millions de dollars, et avoir les mêmes prétentions.
Un machine laser pour découper et faire de l'assemblage 2D et 3D,
des tables traçantes pour usiner le cuivre et faire de l'electromagnitque,
à l'échelle microscopique,
des tours numériques pour les structures précises,
des outils de programmation pour moins d'un dollar,
100 microcontrolleurs cadencés a une nanoseconde. Ca permet de travailler n'importe quoi, du microns
et microseconde jusqu'a plus grand, et c'est en plein explosion dans le monde entier.
Ce n'était pas prévu, mais ça a diffusé depuis le centre de Boston
jusqu'á Pobal en Inde, Secondi-Takoradi sur la côte Ghanéenne
à Soshanguve une banlieue d'Afrique du Sud,
jsuqu au nord de la Norvége, révelant, ou aidant à réveler
avec toute l'attention de la scission numérique,
nous trouvions des ordinateurs usagers dans tous ces pays.
Un fermier dans un petit village -- un enfant qui a besoin de mesurer et de modifier
le monde, non pas juste en aillant des informations sur un écran.
C'est qu'il y a a vraiment une différence entre la fabrication et l'instrumentation,
plus grand que la différence en équipement informatique.
Et la façon de resorber le problème, ce n'est pas de l'IT pour les masses, c est le développement de l'IT pour les masses.
Ainsi, pays après pays,
nous avons vu la même progression: nous ouvrions l'un de ces laboratoires
où --nous n'y avions -- c'était trop fou de penser en installer.
Nous n'avions pas pensé à l'avance, que nous serions attirés par ces sites,
Cette première étape nous a mis en confiance.
Vous pouvez le voir dans leurs yeux, cette joie de, "Je peux le faire".
Ici, c'est une fille dans un quartier du centre de Boston, qui vient juste de faire
un vente sur demande d'un objet high-tech dans un centre communautaire de la ville.
Ca va de ça a des projets éducatifs ambitieux et participatifs
,en dehors de l'école. Au Ghana, nous avons monté un de ces laboratoires.
Nous avons mis au point un détecteur, et les enfants venaient
et refusaient de quitter le labo.
Il y avait cette fille qui insistait pour qu'on reste tard le soir --
(Vidéo): L'enfant: J'adore le labo
-- sa première nuit dans le labo, parce qu'elle était en train de fabriquer le capteur.
Et elle insistait pour fabriquer le circuit imprimé, apprendre comment le monter,
apprendre a le programmer. Elle ne savait pas trop
ce qu'elle était en train de faire, ni pourquoi elle le faisait, mais elle savait
qu'elle devait le faire. I y avait comme quelque chose de mystique.
C'est tard , vous savez, genre 11 heure du soir
et je pense que j'étais la seule personne surprise quand
ce qu'elle venait de construire marcha au premier essai.
Et j'ai montr's cette vidéo a des ingénieurs de grosses entreprises, et ils m'ont avoué
qu'ils ne peuvent pas faire ça. Tous ce qu'elle fait, ils peuvent le faire mieux qu'elle
mais c'est reparti entre plein de personnes et de sites différents
et ils ne peuvent pas faire en une après-midi,
ce que cette petite fille au Ghana faisait.
(Vidéo): La fillette: Mon nom est Valentina Kofi, J'ai huit ans.
Je construis une carte électronique.
Et encore une fois, c'était juste pour le plaisir.
Ensuite, ces laboratoires ce sont attaqués à résoudre des problèmes plus ambitieux --
de l'instrumentation pour l'agriculture en Inde,
des turbines à gaz pour la transformation d'énergie au Ghana,
des antennes à forte amplifications dans des ordinateurs fins,
et de là, cette entreprise a grossi
comme la fabrication de ces antennes.
Et enfin, ces labo ont commencé à découvrir leurs propres inventions.
Nous apprenions plus d'eux que ce que nous leur enseignions.
J'apprenais à ces enfants comment utiliser les laboratoires.
Ils ont inventé comment faire un kit de construction en partant d'un carton --
idée qui, comme vous le voyez, vient d'être commercialisée
mais leur design était meilleur que celui de Saul à MIT,
donc il y a maintenant trois élèves à MIT qui font leurs thèses
sur la généralisation du travail d'un enfant de huit ans,
parce que son design est meilleur.
De vraies inventions sont faites dans ces laboratoires
Et je dis toujours -- l'année dernière, j'ai passé mon temps
avec des chef d'Etats, des généraux et des chefs de tribus, qui veulent tous ça,
et je n'arrête pas de leur dire que ce n'est pas le produit final
Qu'ils attendent 20 ans, et nous aurons fini.
Et j'ai enfin compris ce qu'il se passait. C'est Kernigan et Ritchie
inventant UNIX sur un PDP.
PDPs sont apparus entre l'époque des ordinateurs centraux et des mini-ordinateurs.
Ils coutaient des dizaines de milliers de dollars, étaient difficiles à utiliser,
mais ils donnaient l'accès aux ordinateurs, à plein de groupes de travail
et tout ce que nous faisons aujourd'hui a été inventé à cette époque.
Ces laboratoires ont la complexité et le coût des PDP.
L'image de la fabrication digitale
n'est pas une image du futur. Nous sommes en ce moment dans l'ère du PDP.
Nous n'osions pas parler des grosses découvertes à l'époque.
c'était très cahotique, et ce qui se passait n'était pas très clair.
De la même façon, nous sommes aujourd'hui dans cette période des mini-ordinateurs
de la fabrication digitale.
Le seul problème avec ça, c'est que ça casse les limites conventionnelles.
A Washington, je vais voir toutes les agences gouvernementales qui veulent bien me parler,
A San Fransisco, je vais voir toutes les entreprises auxquelles vous pouvez penser.
Elles sont toutes d'accord pour parler de ça, mais ca casse
toutes les limites organisationnelles. En fait, c'est même illégal pour elles
dans de nombreux cas, d'équiper Monsieur Toulemonde pour créer
au lieu de consommer la technologie.
Et ce problème est si important, que l'invention ultime
venant de ces communautés m'a surpris:
c'est l'ingénierie sociale. Le labo dans le Grand Nord de la Norvège--
si loin au Nord que les antennes satellites pointent le sol
plutôt que le ciel, parce que c'est où sont les satellites--
le labo a grossi bien plus vite que les locaux dans lesquels il était
Il a été mis là parce qu'ils voulaient retrouver les animaux dans les montagnes
mais ça a depassé les attentes, et ils ont construit un village entier autour du labo.
Ce n'est pas une université, ce n'est pas une entreprise; c'est en fin de compte
un village pour l'invention, c'est un village pour les gens en marge de la société
et ceux qui ont grandi autours de ces laboratoires,
partout dans le monde.
Et ce programme s'est transformé en une ONG,
une fondation pour le labo, pour aider au développement, une sorte de fond d'investiment pour ce labo.
La personne qui s'en occupe, decrit ca de façon très juste comme
"des machines qui font des machines ont besoin d'entreprises qui créent des entreprises".
C'est un mutant entre de la micro-finance et des fonds d'investissement
et ensuite, des partenariats avec le MIT pour
rendre tout cela possible.
Et je voudrais conclure avec deux réflexions.
Il y a eu un changement dans l'attribution des aides, depuis les méga-projets centralisés
à des projets décentralisés, la micro-finance investissant à la racine
et tout le monde est d'accord pour dire que c'est ce qui marche.
Mais nous considérons toujours la technologies comme des méga-projets.
Le numérique, les communications, l'énergie pour la planète
se sont des gros projets centralisés.
Si cette salle pleine de héros est suffisamment intelligente,
vous pouvez résoudre les problèmes vous-mêmes.
Le message venant des laboratoires de fabrication, c'est que
les cinq autres milliards d'individus sur cette planète
ne sont pas juste la pour subir la technologie, mais peuvent la créer.
La vraie opportunité, c'est de récolter la puissance innovatrice du monde
pour concevoir et produire localement des solutions aux problèmes locaux.
Je pensais que c'était une projection 20 ans dans le futur,
mais c'est ou nous sommes aujourd 'hui.
Ca casse toutes les frontières organisationnelles auxquelles ont peut penser.
La chose la plus dur aujourd'hui est l'ingénierie sociale
et l'ingénierie organisationnelle.
Et enfin, toute présentation comme celle-ce sur le futur de numérique
se doit de montrer la loi de Moore, mais ma version favorite--
ça, c'est l'originale de Gordon Moore, de son article original--
et c'est ce qui se produit, année après année,
nous avons grandit, grandit, grandit
et encore grandit, grandit, grandit
et encore, et encore
et voila le bug menaçant de ce qui va arriver
à la fin de la loi de Moore; le bug ultime arrive.
Mais nous allons apprecier, une transition du 2D au 3D,
de la programmation des bits à la programmation des atomes,
qui fait de la fin de la loi de Moore, non pas le bug ultime
mais la fonction ultime.
Donc nous sommes juste au bord de la révolution numérique dans la fabrication,
où les résultats des programmes numériques programment le monde réel
Et ensemble, ces deux projets répondent à la question
que je n avais pas posé clairement. Cette classe au MIT montre que l'application ultime
pour la fabrication personnelle dans les pays développés
est la technologie pour un marché à un seul client: l'expression personnelle de la technologie
qui met au jour une passion telle, que je n'ai pas vu
depuis longtemps.
Et l'application utlime pour le reste de la planète, c est l'instrumentation
et la fabrication distribuée: les gens développant des solutions locales
à des problèmes locaux. Merci